hey guys that go the glass is here a
while ago I did my top 20 favorite
movies of all time and a lot of people
seem to like that a lot so this time I'm
gonna do my top 10 favorite comedies now
what I mean by that is not comedies that
totally redefine the way we look at
comedy or which ones were the most
poetic or abstract or anything like that
I'm only going by which one's made me
laugh the most
which one's made me laugh the hardest so
these are the comedies that I can watch
over and over again never get tired of
them they just always inspire me always
make me laugh and I am going to count
them down for you right now so get ready
these are my top 10 favorite comedies
number 10
Hot Shots part do something you're gonna
hear me say often in this countdown is
epic comedy which is a comedy that's not
only funny but has a huge scale in terms
of the story in jokes Hot Shots pardhu
is one of those companies it's a satire
of 80s and 90s action films that's
probably my favorite of the straight-up
parody flicks and don't get me wrong
movies like Young Frankenstein and
airplane are probably much more clever
and groundbreaking than this one but
this just makes me laugh the most I love
it for two reasons one is the main stars
Charlie Sheen and Valeria Galina who
play their parts so straight face and so
serious that makes all the madness
happening around them just seem all the
more hilarious I actually wish they made
more sequels just so they can work
together again the other reason is the
visual jokes which I think this one has
the most of they just threw everything
at you lampooning all the over-the-top
action scenes that we love in so many
other films might tend to be a very
visual guy so these kind of jokes really
make me laugh it makes me laugh every
time and I never get tired of watching
number nine rat race now I'll say right
now that the beginning of this movie and
the ending of this movie is pure crap
it's cheap jokes lame writing and serves
the plot poorly however the middle of
the movie the chase portion is
laugh-out-loud hilarious seeing all
these funny people constantly work off
each other creates a lot of comedic gold
the premise is pretty much just a
rewrite of it's a man man man net world
and to be fair that's probably a much
better movie but again this one just
makes me laugh more particularly these
two brothers play by Seth Green and
Vince values they're both Weasley con
men who constantly get themselves into
trouble one of them pierced his own
tongue which means he's virtually
impossible to understand these two are
the funniest part but the other
characters are really enjoyable too plus
some of these jokes are so beautifully
and abstractly forced that you can't
help but appreciate them for example Jon
Lovitz and his family are driving in
Hitler's car
don't ask when a bunch of bikers attack
them he burns his throat with the
cigarette lighter
he gets black lipstick from earlier on
his face and arrives at a World War two
veterans ceremony now that's really
forced but it's also beautifully
creative how can you not laugh at them I
love the people I love the scenarios and
I love the slapstick with a movie like
this it just can't get silly enough
number eight Life of Brian everybody
always thinks this is a satire on the
life of Jesus when really it's anything
but the focus is not to make fun of
Jesus but rather make fun of the people
who followed him and even then that's
not really mocking religion as it is
mocking misunderstandings look at this
even from the beginning people are
getting things wrong despite the fact
that Jesus is right in front of them to
be taken literally it refers to any
manufacturers product now I had hundreds
of years to that and you could possibly
get a few misunderstandings but what I
love is how much they make the followers
so Michael
they're not evil or bad people they're
just looking for a little more certainty
in their lives and are willing to do
anything and follow anything in order to
make them more confident it's very
clever very carefully written and of
course very silly I personally think
it's one of the best satires ever
written even if it is controversial
still as long as people can keep in mind
that humanity is fallible and has always
made mistakes and will continue to make
mistakes I personally don't see it as
that offensive I'm not anti religion or
anything but everybody can always miss
read something and this movie is pretty
much all about that like most comedies
are and if for some reason you do find
the too offensive that you need to
complain about it just remember
always
number seven blues brothers how can you
be a Chicagoan and not love this movie
if you go down any Chicago Street and
say the line we're on a mission from God
everyone knows what you're talking about
it's a simple premise an orphanage needs
money Jake and Elwood trying to get it
through band gigs yes somehow all this
shit happens I just love how two little
people can cause such a pileup of cars
trucks police military and on top of
that it's all real all the cars piling
up are really piling up all the people
they got are really the people they got
no CG at all that makes it all the more
massive and all the more hilarious for a
slow but sturdy pace we see how all this
trouble comes about and why so many
people want to get these guys I just
love how huge it gets and it's so funny
knowing that all this chaos is caused by
just these two people who in and of
themselves are hilarious on top of that
the jokes are great the music is great
the acting is great it's just an
all-around great film Blues Brothers
music dancing comedy and a shitload of
cars what more do you need
number six Shrek 2 you're probably gonna
be really surprised when I say this but
I'm one of the few people who didn't
like the first Shrek movie I thought the
idea was clever but the jokes were very
few and often not really worked out it
just to make me laugh that much Shrek 2
on the other hand is funny as hell the
amount of jokes they throw out you is
almost overwhelming
there's jokes in the background there's
jokes in the foreground subtle jokes
obvious jokes they're all over the place
the characters themselves are jokes puss
and boots as Zorro is great the fairy
godmother running her own business is
great and on top of that I actually
really buy the love story between Shrek
and Fiona it's surprisingly a very nice
and believable romance well as
believable as it can be with odors it
also looks nice is very colorful and
plus you gotta watch it a few times in
order to get every single joke that they
throw out there everything in this film
works and in my opinion it blows the
original out of the water but maybe
that's just me either way it's one of my
favorites
and that's about it for now stay tuned
for the other top 5 coming soon